a potentially devastating National Rail
strike has been averted after the Senate
joined the house in voting to block it
President Biden said it means that the
U.S economy has avoided a quote
Christmas catastrophe Scott McFarland is
on Capitol Hill for us following all
this Scott Good morning Tony good
morning to you President Biden says
he'll sign this deal as soon as it
reaches his desk using a century-old law
at the president's urging Congress has
intervened in this deadlocked dispute
one day after the U.S house did so the
Senate voted to make the latest rail
industry offer to workers binding that
offer includes a 24 pay raise over five
years for the workers a personal day for
employees and some bonus pay but
Senators didn't approve something which
rail labor unions have been fighting
pretty significantly they wanted seven
days of paid sick leave and the unions
are disappointed they didn't get it
saying rail workers in particular need
the sick time because of the physical
demanding work that often keeps them far
from home home for days at a time this
deal does prevent a walk-off of nearly
115 000 rail workers in snarled holiday
shipping traffic and potentially another
spike in inflation but there are more
deadlines to come two weeks from today
is the deadline for a government
shutdown
negotiations are underway Gail
I feel we've heard that song before or
thank you very much Scott good to see
you